annyeonghaseyo chili to me
mark applier how are you I'm in Korea
and I did the most unoriginal thing I
could possibly think of all I was in
Korea and I got a bunch of Korean candy
to try on camera because my mom we're
not going to be on TV
no TV how popular do you think I am so
if you couldn't tell I'm at my family's
house my house my money she'd be soil
money chibi spit too bad
you saw it oh no my grandma's house as
you can hear rustling beneath me I have
a bunch of Korean candies down here that
I'm gonna be trying and to help me I'm
gonna bring in various members of my
family in here to assist me with this
because well I can't even read half of
these labels so I have no idea what's in
them oh hello come on yeah come on in so
now the room is full of people all
watching me not creepy at all usually I
recorded my room alone but now got the
room of us seven people here watching me
so that's nice okay
tomi hey I can't break anything here
this is my grandma's house if I break
anything here I will be thrown out into
the street I'll be devoured by wolves
this is jang ha ha ha me
Oh chat on me caramel sugar caramel
caramel
come I'm getting a lot of nodding heads
and no yeses candy I can only assume
that it's not any different than
anything I've ever tried in America they
smell there is a smell I don't like that
this says bye Oh peach because in
America if something was vile peach that
suggests it's radioactive
what is radioactive in the Korean
someone tell imagine dragons they don't
have to translate their song to go with
that when it calls me we're really
nothing amazing about this which is
candy and it doesn't video of me want
meeting candy almost marginally better
than the video of me eating pretzels I
guess this one says bio rum no bio plum
sorry bio pineapple why does it say bio
bio ha mom what is this a Bible it says
bio everywhere on the label it wasn't
even buying Oh No by-y-y-y-y-e the brand
alright so tell me what the next one I'm
gonna introduce my first guest
that's what you introduced me this you
responded Domo when I said you responded
though every time I'm like Domo you go
hey yes
you can't blame me touhou is gone I am
so sorry
this is embarrassing for me because I've
been here for four days now and it's
been told every day you didn't do you
you didn't tell me come on okay it's not
okay okay so what is your name I don't
trust you so I'll let you pick whoever
you are
what candy candy I and our according you
couldn't see this but my mom went I saw
means Hey what's okay so you wanna try
the same time
you trust me oh that's so sweet and
naive okay
[Applause]
how strong are your teeth you didn't
make it last though not too fast okay
how do you say broken oh so did I so
that was um some kind of sour candy not
quite equivalent to warheads but I am so
sorry
why is everyone been letting me get away
with this whole time
Oh as if you knew did you know yeah get
up here you're next
jumbaye you wait all right though this
is my brother thumbs Jason it's funny
everyone here fealty days and they
didn't change her name to tonnes until
after you came to Korea yeah yeah wait
when did you start going by Tom's first
a second very early yeah okay that's how
they know you know no one's gonna call
you Tom I'm sorry maybe this is Tom so
you get to pick another candy whatever
this okay the squirty read it why do I
have the reason I can't jostle more in
Tilley
Mandy Mandy Mandy I know
oh man loogie you make jelly
Tata move up hustle today squeeze
that's a persistent activity get squeeze
it
there's a lot of crannies and most
important
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
like why good and what world is this
good good I was not good yeah that was
awful
it tastes like Greece maybe it's because
I put a lot on mine but mine taste is
suspiciously like petroleum got it don't
put it put it where people can see it
where people can appreciate the texture
of it I guess I was I got what I asked
for
so it's like there was a couple of these
and these are juicy drops with other
kind of squeezed flavor and I guess I
had to try it
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so sorry
Oh No okay so maybe this one's gonna be
marginally differently
why isn't there some sort of safety
thing there's not a lot of like sanitary
precautions in a lot of food that I've
seen I was at the grocery store and
there was a hamburger meat though it's
just sitting open and like in table next
to this guy those shouting into a
microphone at the grocery store you know
the guy in the meat department is
shouting into a microphone
we got me come get me except in Korean
you know you're saying that I I know
creepy was saying exactly that anyway
let's try this what world is that good I
only do one by myself and then I know
unless you're gonna tell me that your
name in jung-bae we're gonna have a big
problem all right so this one jumped out
at us it's called pine needle Kitty and
I've heard pine nuts is that the same
kind of deal no different pine nuts I'm
from pinecones our pine nuts from
pinecones
by money you pay your ma how much money
a lot Oh take that bet
oh my god I got I got you okay not that
I've ever eaten a pine needle before but
I got you my mom you can won't you come
up here you volunteer for this are you
dancing your way this is shat sashayed
all right whatever I don't need to put
money here because I know I'm gonna win
this one
I mean it's not exactly an unsafe bet
this it has pine cones and pine needles
on it I'm assuming that doesn't smell
good I didn't say go don't spit it back
out okay we go like what now you feel
the pine needle after I say it doesn't
taste like pine needles you just decided
just take it you know why we have no
idea what it's like the pine needles
smell like so if I said this is like it
it is like it
[Music]
young back are this young bear hi my
name is Tom Weston nice to meet you hmm
he speaks English real good ah thank you
bye Uli's pizza luckily my Korean
teacher is my love I'm sorry all right
so which one of these would you like
finals candy looks candy
really what is this
boy Love Boat king robot King
Oh robot King oh sheesh a a new answer
ty north
HUP two HUP Mooji I know what more than
that okay Oh Oh watch him you know no
hair I you she's dresser back to the
dinosaur I get the toys oh come some me
back don't eat no problem you're welcome
don't worry about it don't worry over I
taught him that I told them it was real
fancy which it is mother's candy yeah
Heidi so no bad it tastes like a worse
Flintstone vitamin okay
[Music]
no Brooke no is it done a little finger
oh he's so cute
here you go ha thank you you're welcome
jinx
anyway young BAE we have pictures
together when we were little babies oh
oh no sir
kazuto-san assets are but five years the
five tiny bit here here they are they
are many pictures they show ya see
they're going by right now oh that one
here thank you
I've got one more guest
if your name changed
introduce yourself here pick this one
how's my hair can you make me like the
kpop you know what was wrong with this
head D oh where was the candy Oh
Maltese that basically Maltese and is
gonna take a while
[Music]
welcome so we've made it through a lot
of candy I think we ran out of special
guests so I guess I gotta carry this on
myself which really reflects my
personality because the next one I
picked was this minion one disgust it
really fascinated me with the fact there
was minion in this
this guy like hey it's my favorite and I
was wayde's favorite horse so I had to
get it but I don't think it'll be
actually any different so I'm assuming
it's just like
mmm there's really nothing different
this isn't megamouth strawberry flavor
and I don't know what strawberries they
drew it from I think they just dilute it
down some cough syrup and put it into a
spray bottle if I want spray hung big it
over just open your mouth
alright so that's just as bad as it
would be in America that was a trash can
minecraft knockoff called sandbox
friends gum gum gum not good so uh
ripoff but a little bit ago I've got
this is Toby
Katie chocolate jelly why would you need
the mixture well I guess the topic
puddings in thing and that's not too far
yes yeah rap a fungus wait you can't
just keep saying words and expect that
to mean anything you don't know you
don't know I know fungus and I know rats
I'm sorry why did it last
where's my glass mom you're hilarious
but hang on do you think it's actually
covered in fungus or do you think it
just looks looks that way from this
distance
whoever you want newett robber rubber
okay yeah I would equated that yes bad
oppression trash it good idea who else
wants to try em bang it's all gonna give
us food poison there Thomas oh shut up
thank you thank you thank you you never
smile I'll fill this in oh now I'm doing
the girl get a little pumpkin how I've
been the little not that bad not that
good
I've got some more candy here but I'm
not even gonna bother it because I I
think I'm about done I wanted to end it
on
I wanted to end it with something that
I'm familiar with because I just wanted
to see how it changed when it came down
to being in Korea if this was made in
Korea then that's good gun she kina I
know 30 years I was marveling why study
in here
booting son went on the onj all these or
not oh okay so in Korea it's a study
snack
tastes like okay so that'll wrap it up
conclusion I went out of my way to pick
the weird ones so I think the fact that
I did that means that I didn't enjoy
some of them but a lot of them just
taste like candy so I don't know what I
expected out of this and I have no
conclusions to draw one way or another
I'm not gonna make any comparisons
because I can't say one's better than
the other so what's the moral of the
story here try different experiences
learn new things to study other cultures
through their candy any level good life
activity with family right right so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you ever want to go to Korea I
recommend it I've been having a great
time with my family been learning a lot
of things got a lot of stories to tell
that I'll tell later but thanks
everybody so much and check out my
various relatives and cousins instagrams
or other social media in the description
below but there thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always bye bye
[Music]